اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه المقابله الخاصه
التي نجريها مع وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
السيد ديفيد كاميرون اهلا بك سيد ديفيد
معنا شرا جزيلا يسعدنا ان نكون معكم لدينا
الان في هذه اللحظات بيان صدر عن الخارجيه
البريطانيه لربما يغير قليلا مجرى هذا
الحوار معك صرحت بانكم تدعمون وقفا فوريا
لاطلاق النار يؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى
وقف شامل من اجل ايقاف هذه الحرب وادخال
المساعدات ما الذي جعل موقفكم يتغير لانه
في المده الماضيه وصلتم الى حد انكم
امتنعت عن التصويت في الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده في اتجاه نفس القرار الذي
وافقت عليه
دوله نحن دائما دعمنا فكره وقفات لاطلاق
النار لكي تدخل المساعدات الى غزه ويخرج
الرهان من غزه لكن ما نقوله اليوم هو اننا
نرى نريد ان نرى اولا وقفا فوريا انسانيا
لانهاء حاله الرهان هذه ونحن بحاجه ماسه
الى ادخال المساعدات وما نقول اننا ننتقل
من هذه الوقفه الى وقف اطلاق النار مستدام
اردنا دائما ان يتحقق من دون ان يلحق ذلك
المزيد من الاعمال العذائيه والقتال
والتدمير في غزه لو حدث هذا فان امورا يجب
ان تتم اولا نريد ان نرى سلطه فلسطينيه
جديده يتم تجديدها ونرى افقا توضع لكي يرى
الشعب الفلسطيني مسارا نحو دوله فلسطينيه
مستقبليه لكن ما هو حيوي النرى ليس كل
رهاء ان يطلق سراحهم فقط ووقف اطلاق النار
بان نرى قاده حماس الاساسيين يتركون غزه
والهيكليه التي تمكنهم من اطلاق الصواريخ
وارتكاب الاعمال الارهابيه يتم تفكيكها
لانه لن يكون بالامكان ادامه اي وقف اطلاق
النار من دون هذه الامور هذه خطتنا وهذا
ما بحثته يوم امس مع الاسرائيليين واليوم
هنا في قطر يعني ما افهمه من حديثك ان
الامر مشروط بشروط قد تكون وفق الكثيرين
غير واقعيه عندما تتحدث عن خروج حماس لانه
هدف اسرائيل لم تستطع ان تحققه حتى الان
وحماس لا تقبل به
اولا ليس هناك ما هو غير واقعي عن وقفه
فوريه لا يمكن ان نترك ذلك لا يمكن ان
نخرج الرهائن من دون ذلك ولا ادخال
المساعدات منكل ذلك الموقف الواقعي هو
اننا ننتقل من هذه الوقفه الى وقف اطلاق
النار من مع بقاء حماس هذا غير واقعي
وحماس تستطيع بعد ذلك اطلاق الصواريخ
واضحا لان اسرائ الاسرائيليين سيعودون الى
القتال لانهاء ذلك الموقف ما ينبغي علينا
ان نقوم به هو ان ننتقل من الوقفه الى وقف
اطلاق النار من دون قتال هذه شروط قد يرى
البعض او البعض الاخر ان يجب ان تتم وصولا
الى وقف اطلاق النار المستدام من جهتنا
نحن نقول هذه الشروط بالحد الادنى
الضروريه ولكن الواقع ان اسرائيل هي من
يرفض وقف اطلاق نار شامل وحماس عرضت ما
يتعلق بهذه الصفقه فيما يتعلق ايقاف اطلاق
النار ايضا تسليم الرهاءن مقابل ايضا
بطبيعه الحال مطالب فلسطينيه
مشروعه واضح نحن لم نصل تلك النقطه التي
يمكن ان نعلن فيها وقفه لاطلاق النار
لكننا لسنا بعيدين ايضا نحن نفهم ان
اسرائيل مستعده لوقفه وهي مستعده لهذا
الاطلاق للرهائن واعتقد انهم تواصلوا مع
القاده هنا في قطر ونحن هنا ايضا نتواصل
مع القاده في قطر لكي نعالج الموقف الموقف
صعب ويزال تفاقما هناك امراض تنتشر هناك
جوع وحتى قبل هذه الوقفه انا كنت في
اسرائيل ومن بين الاسباب التي بحثتها هو
ان تفتح المعابر لفترات اطول نريد لمسؤولي
الامم المتحده في غزه ان يزدادوا عددا وان
يمتلكوا السيارات المصفحه وسمات الدخول
يتنقل في غزه لكي نضمن ان المساعدات
الانسانيه تصل الى الشمال والجنوب وان
يتصل المزيد من المساعدات يجب ان نركز على
هذه الامور طيله الوقت ونحن نفعل ذلك لكن
افضل طريق لذلك هو وقف اطلا الوقفه لاطلاق
النار لنكن صريحين سيد ديفيد لم يكن
خطابكم بهذا الوضو ووح وبهذا الضغط الذي
تتحدث عنه الان في اتجاه وقف اطلاق نار
شامل وادخال المساعدات لغزه في الايام
الماضيه وطوال ثلاثه اشهر ما الذي تغير
الان هل كان يستحق الامر اكثر من 25 الف
شهيد في قطاع غزه من المدنيين حتى تصلوا
الى هذه الصراحه في
الحديث كما قلت دائما نحن دائما كنا نجاد
من اجل وقفه لاطلاق
النار لكي اخراج الرهائن واتقال المساعدات
ايضا وما كنا نتبناه حول ما اسميه ان وجهه
نظر واقعيه وهو واضح ان اسرائيل لن تقبل
بان يكون قتل حماس يديرون غزه ويطلقون
الصواريخ واحتمال ان تقع ح هجمات ارهابيه
على اسرائيل وا اسرائيل لديها حق مشروع في
الدفاع عن النفس كما هو الحال مع اي بلد
هذا هذا كان موقفنا اذا اردت وقفا لاطلاق
النار يجب ان تكون يكون قادرا ان يتحول
الى مستدام ولن يكون مستداما طالما بقي
امكان اطلاق صواريخ من غزه اذا الامر
السهل و الشعبوي هو ان نتحدث عن حاجه لوقف
اطلاق النار مستدام لكن ما نقوله الان
ممكن ان ننتقل من الوقفه الانسانيه الى
وقف مستدام قد لا يكون سهلا لكنه حق
العناء ما سميتموه حق اسرائيل في الدفاع
عن نفسها هو مكان المبرر الذي ساقته في
استمرارها في هذه الحمله العسكريه وهذه
الحرب لمده اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر وقتل كل
هؤلاء الابرياء وتدمير البنيه التحتيه في
قطاع
غزه منذ البدايه قلنا ان اسرائيل بحاجه
الى احترام القانون الانسان الدولي وان
تقلل من الضحايا المدنيين ولم ندعم كل شيء
قامت به اسرائيل حقيقه ان لديهم حق مشروع
في الدفاع عن الامر هو مجرد ذكر و لواقع
الحال الان لديهم الفرصه لتكون هناك وقفه
لادخال المساعدات واخراج الرهان وصولا الى
حل دائم نريده كلنا لكن مهم ان ان يمارس
الناس نفس الضغط على حماس من المستحيل ان
نؤمن بوقف اطلاق النار لو ان الذين اطلقوا
هجمات السابع من اكتوبر يبقون في غزه
ويبقون قادرين على القيام باي شيء لا بلد
لا قطر ولا بريطانيا ولا اي بلد يقبل جارا
قام بهذه الامور وقال انه يريد تكرارها
ويطلق صواريخ على بلدكم ويريد ان يبقى في
ذلك البلد بعد اطلاق وقف اطلاق النار هذا
ليس له مصداقيه وهي واحده من الشروط لكنني
اؤكد على ان من الشروط الاخرى لجعل وقف
اطلاق النار هذا مستداما ان يكون هناك افق
للشعب الفلسطيني يرى دوله فلسطينيه ويرى
الشعب الفلسطيني ان ان سلطه فلسطينيه تدير
غزه وناس فلسطينيون يديرون غزه علينا ان
نميز بين الشعب الفلسطيني وحماس حماس لم
تخدم الشعب فلسطيني جيدا هم الذين جاؤوا
بهذه الفوضه والدمار على رؤوسهم من خلال
اعمالهم الفظيعه في السابع من اكتوبر ولكن
انكم
تربطونه الحدث الاول هنا هي المشكله
الاساسيه وانت في 2014 كنت قد تحدثت عن ان
الوضع في غزه عباره عن معسكر اعتقال وانه
الوضع يجب ان يتغير وانه لا يمكن قبول
استهداف المدنيين وهو ما ينص عليه القانون
الدولي الانساني ما الذي جعلكم هذه المره
تسمحون و تعطون الحق لاسرائيل بمسمى
الدفاع عن النفس في ان في وقت ان الامر
بين بالنسبه لكم ان ما يجري هو قتل
للمدنيين وهي حرب جائه وغير منصفه في حق
المدنيين
نعم انا سمعت وجهه النظر هذه طيله حياتي
في السياسه بان الحل لهذا الوضع هو حل
الدولتين وعندما ترشحت البرلمان في
2001 امنت بذلك وعندما اصبحت رئيس الوزراء
كنت من ذلك وزعيم المحافظين امنت بذلك
واليوم ورغم فضائع اللحظات التي نعيشها ان
يجب ان يجب ان نستغل هذه هذا الوضع من اجل
فرص الفرص تعني وقف اطلاق النار ثم وقف
اطلاق النار دائم وان يكون هذا الوضع غير
قابلا للارتداد عكسيا وبالطبع حتى نصل الى
هناك تبقى القضيه اسرائيل كدوله هي بحاجه
ان تحترمها الدول الاخرى بان لها الحق ان
تعيش ضمن حدودها وان يكون لها الحق في
الدفاع عن نفس كما هو الحال مع ايه دوله
اخرى هذا الموقف الان كيف يمكن ترجمته
بالفعل كيف ستضغط على اسرائيل فيما يتعلق
بهذا الموقف الذي الان تعبرون عنه بشكل
صريح نعم هذا ما كنت اقوم به بالضبط يوم
امس في لقاءاتي مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي واخرين في اسرائيل قلت لهم
عليهم ان يروا في هذا فرصه لاننا في خاتمه
المطاف النزاعات العسكريه ضد منظمات
ارهابيه نادرا ما تنتهي بنص عسكري بل
تتطلب تسويه سياسيه لكي نيز الارهابي عن
الشعب العادي ونعطي الشعب الفلسطيني شعورا
بانه ستكون لهم دوله فلسطينيه ويكون لهم
فرصه للعيش بامن وكرامه وامان هذا ما هو
مطلوبنا الان والرساله التي اوصلت الى
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان وقف اطلاق النار
انساني الان ثم تحويل هذه الوقفه الى وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار وحل سياسي الامر صعب
لهم للغايه هم يعودون الى السابع من
اكتوبر ويج من الصعوبه كيف يروا ان هناك
احتمال قيام دوله حل على اساس الدولتين
لكن اصدقائهم والبلدان الاخرى يجب ان يقول
لهم انظروا الى خبراتنا نحن في التعامل مع
هذه القضايا نحن كان لدينا مشكله في
ايرلندا الشماليه مع الجيش الجمهوري
الايرلندي الوضع كان متشابها لكن احتجنا
الى خطوات سياسيه لايصال الوضع ال كل
الشعبين يمكن ان نعيش في امن وكرامه شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد ديفيد كاميرون وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني شكرا جزيلا
لك